voilà derrière moi vous avez le dernier
trou du parcours du Golf National et
c'est ici même qu'aura lieu dans un peu
moins de 2 ans maintenant la rider Cup
la rider Cup c'est l'événement golfique
le plus spectaculaire au monde en
matière de télévision c'est le troisème
événement après les Jeux Olympique et la
Coupe du monde de football c'est vous
dire que les yeux du monde entier
regarderont vers ici sur ce golf
national vers Versailles vers Paris
enfin tous les yeux du monde entier
seront rivés vers nous alors on va
parler évidemment de golf beaucoup
pendant cette Rider on va en parler avec
vous aussi pendant ces 2 ans qui nous
Spar de cet événement au cours d'un
magazine qui s'adresse évidemment à ceux
qui pratiquent le golf puis à ceux qui
veulent découvrir ce sport et ça
s'appelle par
[Musique]
78 au sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'invité Patrick Schmidlin le fondateur
et PDG de golf plus en une trentaine
d'années il est devenu le numéro 1 des
distributeurs de matériel de golf la
découverte le golf du trembler sur
moldre en plein cœur de la vellée de
Chevreuse à l'ombre d'un château du 18e
siècle c'est l'un des neuf trous
préférés des français depuis qu'il a été
pris en main par son actuel gérant
Emmanuel bachot le témoin Franck Lorenzo
verra dans son académie il enseigne
aussi bien au débutant qu' pro de golf
eux-mêm il nous livre quelques-uns de
ses secrets matériel Raphael Ali prè du
Golf National nous démontrera
l'importance des wedg et comme chaque
mois en fin d'émission le Conseil des
[Musique]
champions je vous propose de retrouver
tout de suite l'invité de ce nouveau
numéro de par 78 c'est le fondateur et
le PDG d'une enseigne que tous les
golfeurs connaissent qui s'appelle Golf
Plus et c'est Patrick
schmidelin bonjour Patrick schmidelin
vous êtes le le fondateur le PDG de de
golf plus alors nous sommes ici à
Orgeval dans le magasin d'Orgeval sur ce
sur cette aventure de golf plus ça a
commencé dans les années 80 82 je crois
voilà exactement 1982 donc j'ai commencé
par une petite boutique hein j'étais
jeune à l'époque souviens rue du
longà fin fond du 17e
absolument donc voilà donc après avoir
fait une école de commerce je me suis
lancé j'ai voulu créer ma propre
entreprise c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il y
avait pas beaucoup de magasins de de
golf au départ j'étais pas spécialisé
golf j'ai toujours vendu du golf par
passion et puis à un moment donné je me
suis dit bon allez on se lance à fond
dans le golf et c'est ce que j'ai fait
pour créer par la suite pas mal de
magasins en France et à l'étranger al il
faut dire que vous êtes d'une famille de
golfeurs he chez vous tout le monde joue
au golf tout à fait euh mes parents
jouaient au golf de la Boulie euh dans
les Yveline mon frère ma sœur qui a eu
un très bon niveau
également éip France qui a été en équipe
de France qui gagn les Internationaux de
de France donc tout a été fait par
passion j'ai pu transmettre ça également
à mes enfants qui viennent de me
rejoindre est-ce que c'est venu de de
cette idée en fait c'était assez
difficile dans les années 80 de se
procurer bah des sacs des clubs des de
l'équipement quoi en France oui c'était
et en plus le magasin le matériel onait
pas tout en plus tout tout oui mais le
matériel était assez cher en plus donc
nous ça ça a pas été très compliqué je
dirais dès le départ de faire des prix
beaucoup plus bas que ce qui était
pratiqué en France et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque avveit des écarts de prix
importants avec l'Angleterre les
États-Unis comment vous avez fait pour
réduire ces prix parce que tout le monde
disait bah voilà ça s'importe c'est
fabriqué aux
États-Unis donc ça ça coûte cher il y a
des droits de doine et cetera comment
vous avez fait vous pour baisser un peu
les prix en réduisant les marges he tout
simplement c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
j'étais un petit magasin pas beaucoup de
charg c'est moi qui étais à la vente en
permanence un vendeur et cetera donc en
réduisant au maximum les charges euh on
a pu pratiquer des prix beaucoup plus
bas que ce qui se qui était pratiqué à
l'époque alors il y a ce petit local de
la rue du lond de 17e et puis votre
première boutique au fond que vous décz
r boulevard perè alors voilà boulevard
perè où je trouve un magasin beaucoup
plus grand et là c'est un peu la rupture
avec les autres sports puisque là je
décide de faire que du golf voilà que du
golf voilà après on a ouvert une
boutique à Cannes à sainclou à Garche et
aujourd'hui bah il y a une vingtaine de
boutiques avec des boutiques même
parfois très pointues puisque à Garche
saintclou on a ouvert une boutique
spécialement pour les gaucher donc chose
qui n'existe pas du tout du tout et là
on fait ben il y en a pas mal hein
finalement et et donc là on fait tous
les clubs tous les produits de tous les
fabricants tous ceux qui font des des
clubs gauchers ont vend ça dans cette
boutique là et c'est une boutique qui a
beaucoup de succès on a également créé
une agence de voyage spécialisée dans
les voyages golfic parce qu'on se rend
compte que les golfeurs bah ils aiment
bien l'hiver partir un peu au soleil et
cetera donc on a également ouvert une
agence de voyage qui est également
boulevard Perre il y a un peu plus de 30
ans quand vous créez golf plus est-ce
que vous imaginiez l'expension que ça a
pris aujourd'hui disons que j'étais déjà
installé quand il y a eu le boom du golf
où là il y avait des fortes
augmentations du nombre de licenciés du
golf c'est quoi c'est les années 90 90
voilà donc là là là vraiment il y avait
de plus en plus de licenciés et donc
j'étais déjà organisé déjà installé déjà
plusieurs boutiques ce qui m'a permis de
pas prendre le train en marche il y en a
eu d'autres qu'on essayé mais c'est vrai
que il faut bien connaître faut il y a
des personnes qui venaient de de
d'autres secteur l'fi et cetera mais on
s'improvise pas vendeur de matériel de
golf comme ça il faut quand même bien
connaître faut avoir des vendeurs
pointus bien formé et voil c'est ce que
vous avez fait c'estàd que tous vos
vendeurs sont des bons joueurs de golf
he oui oui oui oui ça c'est impératif
des bons conseillers impératif on peut
pas se avoir des vendeurs comme
certaines enseignes multisport ou ce
sont des vendeurs qui passent d'un rayon
à un autre et qui ne connaissent pas
forcément bien bien les produits donc
nous tous nos vendeurs sont golfeurs ils
sont tous passionnés certains ont des
des très très bon niveau même des
anciens pros aussi comme David
d'ailleurs le responsable de la boutique
d'Orgeval voilà donc on essaie vraiment
d'avoir des personnes très très
expérimentées la grande évolution
maintenant c'est avoir des clubs
vraiment adaptés au joueurs donc le
fitting se développe beaucoup dans tous
nos magasins on le fitting c'est ce qui
permet de de d'avoir le club qui vous
correspond quoi voilà des clubs sur
mesure en fonction de votre taille de la
vitesse de votre swing d'avoir le le
manche le chat
le plus adapté possible et de rectifier
même des trajectoires de balle si vous
faites un peu de Fed un peu de de de
Hook et cetera de hauteur de balle bon
voilà pour les les bons joueurs c'est
vraiment très très bien de pouvoir faire
des des fittings donc on a mis ça en
place on est bien équipé dans tous nos
magasin plus en région parisienne deux
centres extérieurs sur l'hippodrome de
saint-clou et sur l'hippodrome de
Longchamp où là on a également des
centres de de feitting il y a aussi une
chose que vous faites c'est que bah on
peut vous revendre les clubs qu'on
acheté il y a une sorte d'Argus que vous
avez créé voilà on a créé un argus
puisque ça n'existait pas et donc toute
personne qui vient acheter du nouveau
matériel des bois ou des fers on lui
reprend son ancien matériel et on déduit
directement de de l'achat al ce que
j'aimerais bien c'est que vous n fassiez
visiter l'entrepô pour voir voilà bien s
ave plaisir où tout le matériel se
[Musique]
trouveord alors patriidelin là nous
sommes dans dans l'autre
de golf plus à Orgeval pas très loin du
du magasin c'est combien 100 1800 1800
m² et c'est ici que nous stockons toute
la marque greens puisque c'est une
marque que nous avons en exclusivité que
nous fabriquons que nous élaborons et
donc tous les produits sont stockés ici
et partent ensuite dans les magasins
donc là tous ces cartons qu'on voit là
c'est des c'est des produits c'est des
sacs c'est des voilà des sacs des
chariots des tenu de pluie tous les
accessoires les TI et cetera donc il y a
effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
produits et puis également d'une gamme
de textile aussi alors cette marque
Green elle date de quand alors nous
avons créé cette marque il y a 5 ans
maintenant ce sont des produit de
qualité et surtout d'un très bon rapport
qualité-prix quoi des prix vraiment très
très bien placés pour une qualité
équivalent des des grandes marques alors
évidemment c'est fabriqué par les mêmes
fabricants que les autres marques mais
il y a un intermédiaire de moins
absolument c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à
faire des prix vraiment très
intéressants sur cette marque là qui
commence à se développer parce qu'on
commence à avoir de la demande de
magasin ou de prhop qui veulent
distribuer la marque alors il y a la
marque Green et puis il y a aussi le le
site internet et c'est d'ici que partent
les les commandes absolument notre site
internet c'est beaucoup développé ces
dernières années actuellement on a quand
même 5000 connexions par jour au début
quand on a lancé ce site il y avait une
puis deux personnes aujourd'hui il y a 7
ou h personnes qui travaillent en
permanence sur le site on traite une
centaines de commandes par jour un
client qui passe une commande le matin
l'expédition par l'après-midi il peut
recevoir sa marchandise dès le lendemain
l'évolution alors de de GOF plus depuis
les années 80 le le chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui on peut on peut le donner
oui tout à fait on réalise 17 millions
de de chiffres d'affaires sur le marché
français et dans les années 80 c'était
combien oh quand on a démarré bah on est
vite arrivé à 1 2 3 millions puis après
avec l'ouverture des magasins en moyenne
un magasin fait à peu près 1 million de
de chiffres d'affaires donc c'est une
affaire qui est dans en pleine expansion
comme le golf les en France est-ce que
puisquon parle aussi de la rider Cup
dans dans dans ce magazine est-ce que
vous sentez déjà un petit peu
l'influence de oui tout à fait parce
qu'on commercialise dans nos magasins
donc des produits avec le logo rider Cup
des balles des accessoires des vêtements
et cetera des et donc on commence à
sentir vraiment un engouement pour les
produits rider Cup 2018 alors merci
beaucoup Patrick Schmidlin ce que je
vous propose maintenant on va vous faire
swinger on va vous faire faire quelques
taper quelques balles et puis on va
faire examiner votre swing je sais que
vous jouez très bien mais quand même il
peut-être
avec plaisir
[Musique]
par le swing de Patrick schmidelin nous
paraît excellent à nous mais on va quand
même le faire examiner par notre pro
préféré Sébastien Russier bonjour à tous
bienvenue au golf national alors ce que
l'on peut observer au vu des images
qu'on m'a transmises de Monsieur
schmidelin VO qu'il a effectivement un
bon swing une face un petit peu fermée
au sommet voilà certaines petites choses
qu'on peut observer son corps a tendance
notamment son bassin à être un petit peu
trop figé dans le démarrage du mouvement
et ce qui occasionne un club qui va
venir se placer un tout petit peu trop
par ici voyez et qui ensuite lui donne
un plan un peu vertical avec une face
fermée qui l'oblige derrière à
simplement lever le pied droit très très
vite pour ramener le club de l'intérieur
et logiquement au vu de ce que je peux
observer sur son swing on pour pourrait
dire que c'était plutôt un joueur de dro
un exercice qui pourrait être tout à
fait adapté à ce genre de problème c'est
de positionner le club dans le nombril
de se positionner en posture et à partir
de là de chercher à maintenir cette
relation entre le club et le nombril de
manière à ce que ça l'oblige à ouvrir
très légèrement son bassin au démarrage
de manière à ce que cette relation entre
le club et le milieu du corps soit un
peu mieux conservée ce qui lui
permettrait d'avoir d'utiliser plus les
chaînes musculaires du bas du corps ce
qui lui permettrait au retour de
développer plus plus de puissance et
également de ne plus avoir à compenser
par ce mouvement de glisse avec des
appuis qui ont tendance à fuir un peu
rapidement notamment le talon droit qui
se décolle trop vite et qui peuvent
amener un peu d'irrégularité au niveau
de la direction et du
[Musique]
contact
je vous propose de rejoindre tout de
suite Emmanuel bachot qui a repris il y
a un peu plus de 3 ans le golf du
trembler sur moldre qui en est le
directeur mais plus que ça il en est
aussi le propriétaire et aussi
l'â bonjour Emmanuel bachot vous êtes le
le directeur du golf du tremblé sur
moldre alors on dit directeur mais on va
on va voir que vous nêtes pas tout à
fait directeur comme les autres vous
êtes aussi un peu le propriétaire de ce
golf vous avez repris il y a 3 ans oui
un peu plus de 3 ansaintenant 3 ans et
demi effectivement euh donc je me suis
lancé dans l'aventure j'étais j'étais
golfeur bien sûr auparavant mais je suis
indépendamment de ça chef d'entreprise
j'ai une autre structure dans le monde
du loisir depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années dans le monde
événementiel et loisirs et je me suis
lancé dans l'aventure lorsqu'il y a eu
un appel d'offre sur le golf du Tremblet
je d bah j'y vais ça me passionne
j'adore monter des nouveaux dossiers et
puis on a eu la surprise entre
guillemets d'être retenu et c'est vous
qui avez été pris voilà on a été pris et
hop et là il y a fallu en 2 mois et demi
de se dire bah faut que j'apprenne tous
les métiers du golf alors en 3 ans et
demi vous êtes devenu l'un des neuf
troupes préférés des français quand même
oui 6e neuf trous préférés des français
donc on a été très fier de cette de
cette note c'est très bien alors que
alors que voilà il y avait du boulot
quoi quand quand vous l'AVE ouais ouais
il y a énormément de boulot parce que le
site était magnifique et est magnifique
mais avait été laissé entre guillemets
un peu à la band donc par les
prédécesseur et donc le challenge était
important puisque le site étant
magnifique il fallait que le terrain
redeviennent jouaes et deviennent
agréables donc on on sait tous lorsqu'on
parle au golfeur bah ils sont attentifs
effectivement à l'état du terrain c'est
déjà la base euh et on a fait en sorte
en 3 ans et demi de le faire revenir et
dans un cadre aussi joli que ça les gens
ont envie de venir alors on parle de
neuf trous mais il faut préciser que
c'est un vrai neuf trous he par 36 hein
oui l'image des neuf trous en France
c'est un peu le compact urbain euh où on
est en par 30 31 32 non on est en par 36
il y a deux par 5 c'est un vrai 2018
3000 m des blanc des départs blanc voilà
on met équipe de 4 on met 2h de pour
jouer voilà donc il y a on parlait du
château ber il a le parc anglais qui est
un très beau compact cette fois-ci pit
and Paron est en par
27 mais qui fait une belle distance
quand même 800 m donc c'est pas le tout
petit pit et lui pour travailler tout ce
qui est il est extraordinaire voà et ça
c'est plutôt l'Académie on en parlera
voilà l'Académie utilise cet outil qui
est extraordinaire c'est l'ancien site
d'entraînement du Pôle France quand même
savoir 3h de vous avez réussi à imp
planter une sorte d'art de vivre ici
ouais absolument alors c'est c'est c'est
un état d'esprit c'est une ambiance
issue du monde événementiel loisir je
suis forcément dans cet esprit essayer
de la pororter au golf je pense que les
gens ont du mal à franchir la porte d'un
golf voilà tout simplement parce peurou
ils ont de l'appréhension par rapport à
l'image que le golf donne un corp il
faut enlever cette crainte de franchir
une porte d'un golf et il faut savoir
accompagner les gens apporter un maximum
de
service bien manger c'est voà c'est
voilà donc donc faites très attention à
ça voilà que les gens soi so sonent chez
eux soit bien accueilli puissent
puissent rester longtemps s'ils veulent
voilà et qui que les gens se sentent
bien voilà accompagné on leur dit
bonjour on leur dit au revoir et pendant
leur temps de présence et ben on est à
leur côté le plus possible bien sûr et
et puis a il y a tout ce qui est
l'apprentissage du golf avec l'Académie
ça c'est important je je crois sans trop
me tromper qu'il y a environ 30 % de
golf qui arrête après 3 ans il faut
réussir à trouver du résultat et trouver
du résultat seul c'est très compliqué
c'est un des sports quand même assez
compliqué par contre le geste de golf
doit rester simple plus il est compliqué
plus on Storti plus moins on tapablee
dans la balle donc ça doit rester simple
et il faut être
accompagné de pro d'accord sur une
méthodologie toute simple la plus simple
possible pour essayer de simplifier et
donc moi ce que j'ai envie de faire
c'est de de proposer à nos abonnés à nos
à nos à nos clients fidèles et à tous
ceux qui veulent bien sûr le devenir de
ne pas faire que s'abonner mais il dans
leur abonnement dans leur mode de
fonctionnement il ils voi un pro une
fois par mois voilà il le voi une fois
par mois voilà et il le voi une fois par
mois et à partir de là ils sont jamais
seuls ils nonont jamais sent seul euh
sentir seul pardon et les petites
correction vont arriver
on on s'en va très vite hein
techniquement on est bien lendem
la mme chose il s'est passé quelque
chose t c'est pas bon donc là
le voilà et là on a on doit plus avoir
envie de s'arrêter on doit avoir envie
de dire aux autres viens golfer c'est
bien on n pas perdu je pense qu'à un
moment le golfeur est un peu perdu on se
prend la tête et on se prend la tête on
se prend la tête et donc voilà faut
enlever cette image il faut on va en
parler tout à l'heure avec Fran mais un
mot pour venir jouer ici alors il on
peut être membre alors bien sûr on peut
être membre on peut être de passage il
aucun problème
un a de Bill les bar cl syè j'aime bien
dire ça c'est pas de 6e golf préféré de
TR préféré pour rien ouais je pense ou
bravo merci beaucoup merci à vous merci
[Musique]
beaucoup
le témoin de ce numéro c'est Franck
Lorenzo vera c'est le fondateur de
l'Académie de golf du tremblé sur moldre
il prodique son enseignement aux
débutants aux professionnels et même aux
enseignants je suis en compagnie de
Franck laorenz verra bonjour bonjour
Patrice alors on va parler de l'Académie
du golf de trembl surm dont vous êtes le
le le fondateur don vous êtes
l'animateur mais d'abord un petit mot
sur vous vous êtes vous êtes basque
ouais très fier de l'être même bah oui
comme tous les Basques bien sûr vous
vous avez commencé jeun moi j'ai
commencé à 12 euh j'ai arrêté à 13 14
parce que je préférais le rugby il y a
le rugby oui aussi là-bas après vu mon
gabarit comm pouz le constater Ben a
priorie ça sert pas ça pas ça a pas pu
faire carrière et ah domine mêlé non
ouais fait domine mêlé en 1975 ça serait
passé non non non non non non ils sont
costaud donc je me suis réorienté sur le
golf
euh que j'ai que que j'ai pratiqué avec
Jean la maison là-bas grand enseignant
qui m'a tout appris qui d'ailleurs
appris beaucoup de choses à mon petit
frère aussi et euh et qui nous a donné
la piqûre golf en fait cette passion et
et puis maintenant qui fait ma vie et
qui fait votre vie alors Fran l'une de
de vos particularités c'est que vous
êtes formé auprès des plus grands pros
bien sûr alors que ce soit avec le le
journal du golf magazine l'équipe euh
quand on partait aux États-Unis pour
aller pour aller voir Shan Foly ou Jim
mlin au contact ensuite avec les joueurs
que j'entraîne sur le CIRC européen avec
Pete Cohen Jos van sput des avec des
avec des grands noms ou même tout
simplement boî du Colombier Olivier
l'église qui sont qui sont bah qui sont
des machines alors vous êtes intéressé
évidemment à l'enseignement et et à la
manière d'enseigner le golf et c'est ça
un peu l'Académie hein B l'Académie
c'est c'est avant tout montrer à tout le
monde que la technique est là pour
rendre le golf simple rendre l'activité
facile donc la recherche elle est elle
est sur déjà premièrement former mes
enseignants pour qu'il puisse
transmettre un message simple et
efficace pour rendre la pratique ludique
et efficace et performante euh sur les
élèves et aux élèves leur montrer que en
fait c'est pas si compliqué que ça
d'apprendre à tenir un club et
d'apprendre à s'amuser avec c'est
amené
l'enseignement dans son réel but qui est
de rendre efficace la pratique h point
c'est aussi simple que ça et à part
qu'il y en a qui vont faire du golf pour
gagner leur vie il y a des il y en a qui
vont faire du golf pour prendre plaisir
tout simplement et je trouve ça même
presque plus noble d'enseigner
l'enseigner le golf à des gens pour
qu'ils prennent plaisir vous diriez que
c'est plus difficile presque de
s'occuper des des des débutants que des
pr il y a beaucoup de beaucoup de
travail de beaucoup de travail de
communication avec ces gens-là
euh beaucoup de beaucoup d'empathie fa
faire preuve d'énormément d'empathie
parce que on a besoin de savoir d'où ils
viennent qu'est-ce qu'ils font comment
ils sont qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait comme
activité pour essayer de de les orienter
au mieux sur ce sur les les canaux de
communication qu'il sur sur lesquel ils
peuvent raisonner et rebondir au fond
l'une des choses les plus compliquées
c'est d'être simple oui bien sûr c'est
je m'amuse un petit peu à dire à dire ça
souvent je suis un antiméthodique
c'est-à-dire que j'utilise pas une mé
j'essaie d'utiliser l'ensemble des
méthodes pour être la boîte à outil moi
je suis juste là je suis la boîte à
outil de l'élève c'est lui le chef moi
je suis juste je suis juste la personne
qui va aller rechercher où où aller
impacter pour que ce soit efficace et
ici vous êtes aidé par des ensignants je
suis aidé par de super enseignant il y a
Frédéric constant qui est responsable de
l'Académie et Hugo Jacquelin qui vient
de nous rejoindre non connu du golf
aussi en fait on ESTs de rap jaqus de
rapl Jacquelin qui qui nous a rejoint
cette année alors fr l'Académie elle est
ouverte à tout le monde moi je peux
venir par exemple bien sûr c'est même
conseiller à priori vous avez de boulot
mais bien sûr c'est ouvert à tout le
monde moi je suis a pas il y a pas que
les les les les adhérents de de trembler
qui non bien sûr que non non non bien
sûr au contraire c'est l'idée d'ouvrir
de démocratiser réellement et pas de
populariser l'enseignement du golf c'est
le démocratiser permettre à tout le
monde de pouvoir y accéder avec la plus
grande qualité d'enseignement possible
en tout cas on a la volonté de de servir
au maximum les les gens qui découvrent
bah bravo alors parce que vous allez
former plein de golfeurs peut-être que
c'est vous qui allez former le le
français qui sera à la rider Cup je le
souhaite hein respect je le souhaite
merci beaucoup Fran merci
[Musique]
Patrice des coups redoutés des golfeurs
ben c'est le coup d'approche soit dans
le bunker soit au côté du bunker alors
pour ça il y a des des club qui
s'appelle le wedge mais est-ce qu'il en
faut un seul ou plusieurs dans ton sac
bah c'est ce que va nous dire raphaë
àipre bonjour à toutes et à tous
Aujourd'hui je vais vous aider à choisir
vos wedge donc ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que les wedge sont une
grande famille qui va du piting wedge au
love wedge donc pour un peu plus
d'explication en général le pitching
wedge est inclus dans la série que vous
achetez qui va du pitch offer 5 ou
offire 4 et ensuite vous avez besoin
d'autes club notamment pour jouer autour
des Green donc un club qui va être
indispensable va être le sandwedge qui
fait en général 56° qui est un club
assez ouvert surtout qui est rebondi en
dessous pour pouvoir glisser dans le
sable et non pas s'enfoncer dans le
sable maintenant ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que du pitching wedge
au faire 4 dans votre série vous aurez 4
degrés d'écart de loft donc le loft est
en l'angle représenté ici entre la
droite et l'ouverture qui permet donc
d'avoir une certaine distance de jeu si
vous n'avez qu'un piting wedge et un
sand wedge cet écart va être de 12°gr ce
qui est assez important donc il convient
très régulièrement de pouvoir mettre un
gap wedge un club à 50°r qui va pouvoir
vous permettre d'avoir un plein coup
entre le piting wedge et le sand wedge
très important de nos jours il faut bien
comprendre que 70 % des coups de golf
sont joués à moins de 70 m donc avant de
s'équiper sur le long jeu qui est aussi
indispensable mettez d'abord beaucoup de
club au petit jeu ça vous sera beaucoup
plus utile autre utilité ça va être
autour du Green autour du Green ces
clubs ont différents dessins et
permettent donc d'avoir soit une semelle
qui va bien glisser sur l'herbe ce qui
sera le cas des gap wedge et des
pitching wedge ou au contraire pour
pouvoir jouer dans le sable d'avoir un
gros rebond qui permettra de glisser
dans le sable ce qui est le cas du
sandwedge autre option possible vous
aurez le 60° qui est un lob wedge qui
lui va aider les joueurs qui sont en
difficulté pour pouvoir lever la balle
très très fréquemment pardon en venant
plutôt de l'herbe que du sable donc pour
résumer swedge indispensable à avir dans
sa série pour tout niveau de jeu dès
qu'on commence à avoir un un petit peu
de distance de vol le 50°gr qui est un
gap wedge va être lui aussi
indispensable pour le plein coup mais
aussi au bord du green et le 60°g va
être l'option lob wedge pour les joueurs
qui ont besoin de lever la balle
facilement moi qui ai toujours rêvé de
taper fort avec mon driver aujourd'hui
j'ai de la sence je reçois dans l'astuce
du champion Johanna claten numéro 1 de
la driveing distance sur le LPG bonjour
Johanna bonjour Patrice Johanna on
arrive sur ce par 5 dans la zone de
vérité pour moi c'est le ti départ je
vais poser ma balle je vais mettre mon
ti et j'ai un drive à faire est-ce que
tu peux m'aider et bien sûr Patrice
alors je vais vous donner mes petits
secrets donc pour moi le donc la
puissance au driving ça part d'un d'un
grand relâchement souvent souvent je je
vois surtout ça chez les amateurs euh
ils ont tendance à penser que pour taper
fort il faut il faut faut se crisper
faut mais au contraire faut lâcher toute
tension on le voit très bien avec des
très grands fapeurs que comme Booba
Watson Nicolas colsart on sent qu'il y a
il y a une grande fluidité dans leur
mouvement donc déjà quand vous vous
mettez l'adresse je relâcher relâcher
tout ce qui est avant-bras
épaule évidemment il faut il faut une
une bonne posture euh mais après après
il faut pas de tension ici
ensuite
euh c'est au niveau du donc une fois que
vous avez fait V back swing donc là
reprise d'appui est très importante pour
la puissance vous regardez avec Rory
Melroy ça part des hanches et une
extension des jambes et c'est ça qui
c'est ça qui va donner de la vitesse en
plus du relâchement donc pour moi c'est
vraiment deux clés très importantes du
swing pour pour obtenir de la puissance
relâchement reprise d'appui par les
hanches et extension dans la zone de
frappe voilà c'est ça tu nous montres
bien
sûr
quelle
patate
fantastique
voilà tu m'as vendu du
[Musique]
rêve mais je crois qu'on a tout compris
on est prêt à mettre des grosses patates
dans la lcarne grâce à Johann merci
merci
Patrice
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de par
[Musique]